you can catch sylvester stallone in the
series premiere of tulsa king from the
top flies
my character he's a lifetime gangster he
went to prison for 25 years kept his
mouth shut and now he comes out and he's
given some obscure assignment to go to
tulsa and start a mop and that's when
the fun begins
it's a joke
tulsa king is basically a western and a
mob story and mark sly's first lead role
in a scripted tv series all 10 episodes
will stream on paramount plus well i've
always wanted to play a gangster but it
never happened are you in town is it
that obvious it's the equivalent the
schedule of doing five movies back to
back with no break it's a bullet train
it takes a toll so as long as the kids
are still talking to me it's all good
one of sly's three daughters 20 year old
scarlett actually has a cameo in the
show and speaking of cameos i feel like
yellowstone could use a gangster to
shake up some things with the duttons
i like the way you roll i've known kevin
for like centuries too that'd be great
good man
[Music]
you